vous voyez là vous me voyez alors dans
les relais d'allah dans les questions de
la famille hanouna il y a alors j'y vais
c'est parti d'un patrick merci de te
prêter aux yeux je t'embrasse bien fort
toute l'équipe et moi-même se joue à
lyon c'est bon ça
donc plutôt michel drucker ou jean
pierre foucault cours c'est trop
compliqué les deux voilà je suis désolé
donc plutôt nabila où loana nabila alors
plutôt les marseillais à rio ou rendez
vous en terre inconnue
rendez vous en terre inconnue ce que ces
magnifiques quoi ces messieurs une
émission que j'aurais adoré adoré faire
plus tôt enora malagré ou valérie bénaïm
les deux sont tellement charmante et
voilà donc je dirais plutôt à voir les
valérie bénaïm voilà plutôt confiance
you confessions intimes ou strip tease
confessions intimes
même si moi je suis super pudique et
même si je parle absolument pas de de ma
vie privée
plus tôt ce vol se nouvelle star the
voice mois la wii à mes potes tu
cherches pas comprendre plutôt la chance
aux chansons l'eurovision l'eurovision
mais la chance aux chansons
c'est un garçon qui s'appelle qui
s'appelle pascal sevran mal m'avait
donné la possibilité de m'exprimer dans
ses premières émissions donc sa légende
la première heure il y en a pas beaucoup
et ce monsieur en a fait partie mais
l'eurovision c'est vraiment ce qui s'est
passé demain ça a été un moment fort on
a été 2 a terminé quatrième
il ya eu natasha st pier et moi sur 25
pays pas mal quand même
depuis ta la joie plutôt cyril hanouna
ou patrick sébastien ouais ouais mais
les deux alors je connais beaucoup mieux
patrick sébastien est bien moins cyril
hanouna
j'ai rencontré sur europe 1 mais il me
tarde de te découvrir cyril encore plus
plutôt pyramide ou motus away moment
motus
un rien que pour le générique je dirais
motus là ce qui nous a bien traumatisée
suis là et il continue